why is the speaker second in succession
to the president after the vice
president the idea of succession
actually is
was a little muddied and it didn't it
wasn't until the 25th amendment that
actually uh the relationship between the
president and the vice president was
actually formalized when william henry
harrison died and john tyler
came in at his vice president as
president there was a big debate about
whether uh he was actually the really
the president um so even though the line
of succession is uh
uh
is written down there's a lot of debate
about whether what enforces it and what
doesn't it the speaker of the house
though has prominence in that line of
succession because the speaker of the
house is closest to the people and the
formation of the federal government
article one defines the powers of
congress because the framers wanted
congress really to be the powerful
branch close to the people they were
worried about a monarchy so they didn't
want the president to have excessive
power and the speaker of the house
represents all of the you know is
elected by all of the members and so has
a closer relationship uh to the people
and that's what gives them power in the
question of succession what's
interesting though is that there's only
been one speaker of the house who's then
gone on to be president james k polk
so while they are high up in the order
of succession behind the vice president
that doesn't necessarily make the job a
stepping stone
to actual power of the presidency
through the electoral process